valéry giscard d'estaing en valais rien
des cérémonies dans toute la france pour
l'anniversaire du 18 juin 40
la crise sans doute évité en israël le
gouvernement béguines trouvent un
compromis sur la cisjordanie week-end de
travail pour 340 mille jeunes gens les
épreuves du bac commence demain le
tiercé d'auteuil il fallait jouer le 17
le 10 et le 1
madame mademoiselle monsieur bonsoir
la france a perdu une bataille mais la
france n'a pas perdu la guerre
cette phrase historique du général de
gaulle était présente aujourd'hui dans
les mémoires de plusieurs centaines de
milliers de français par un temps
pluvieux et brumeux ce matin sous
quelques rayons de soleil cet après midi
et ce soir les français se sont souvenus
clia 38 ans à londres
un général alors inconnu au plus fort de
la défaite avaient fait souffler les
squares ce matin à colombey les deux
églises des messes ont été célébrées et
puis monsieur alain peyrefitte a déposé
au nom du gouvernement une gerbe de
fleurs sur la tombe du général vers
11h30 c'est monsieur michel debré qui
lui aussi a déposé une gerbe
cet après midi à 16 heures le souvenir
du général de gaulle et celui du général
leclerc ont été étroitement mêlés à la
porte d'orléans
le chef de l'état président est un
solennel hommage à la mémoire du
libérateur de paris et puis à 19 heures
le président de la république s'est
rendu comme chaque année au mont
valérien
de nombreuses personnalités étaient
présentes lors de l'émouvante cérémonie
de la place d'orléans à l'endroit même
où le général leclerc et les trains dans
paris à la tête de la 2e db le 25 août
44 suivi de raymond barre et d'yvon
bourges
le président de la république a d'abord
passé en revue les troupes du régiment
de marche du tchad
puis accompagnant la maréchal leclerc il
a déposé une gerbe au pied de la statue
restaurée après l'attentât commis l'an
dernier ensuite le président a évoqué la
carrière de celui qui par son courage et
sa compétence libera paris puis
strasbourg
du soldat il avait la compétence
il avait aussi le courage ce courage
dont il est inutile de faire l'éloge ici
car c'est le courage militaire de la
france
un courage sobre naturelles dont notre
jeunesse est encore quand il le faut
donner l'exemple
le président de la république est
reparti après avoir serré les mains des
anciens de la 2e division blindée au son
de l'hymne national joué par la musique
de la marine nationale
le chef de l'état s'est ensuite rendu au
mémorial du mont valérien à l'endroit
même où 5000 combattants de la france
libre ont été fusillés pendant
l'occupation
comme les autres années valéry giscard
d'estaing s'est recueilli quelques
instants dans la crypte
le président de la république a serré la
main des compagnons avant de passer les
troupes en revue
en compagnie du chancelier de l'ordre de
la libération monsieur hettier de
boislambert
par la suite le chef de l'état a signé
le livre d'or du mont valérien
puis il a avant de regagner le palais de
l'elysée saint louis les nombreuses
personnalités présentes à cette
cérémonie
en cette journée du souvenir la
politique et le pardon
c'est un peu mise en sommeil à trois
exceptions toutefois d'abord dans quatre
villes de france et électeurs étaient
appelés aux urnes aujourd'hui
il s'agit cette élection municipale
rendue nécessaire par l'annulation des
scrutins de l'année 1977 quatre
élections
aix-en-provence brillant sion flair et
obernai aucun résultat nous est encore
parvenu nous pourrons sans aucun doute
vous les communiquer dans notre dernière
édition vers 23h15 le parti des forces
nouvelles lui a tenu un congrès
aujourd'hui en présence de délégations
italiens espagnols belges et libanaise
de décisions ont été prises lors de ce
congrès le pfn présentera une liste
conduite par m tixier vignancour lors
des prochaines élections aux à
l'assemblée parlementaire européenne et
le pfn sera aussi présent lors des
présidentielles de 1981 mais l'événement
de la journée en politique c'était le
retour à l'avant-scène du monde
politique français d'un homme qui
aujourd'hui apparaît presque comme un
homme seul à quelques kilomètres de
colombey les deux églises
monsieur michel debré est entré en
campagne contre le parlement européen un
appel solennel de l'ancien premier
ministre du général de gaulle pour
refuser toute limitation de
l'indépendance nationale
un refus très ferme de la
supranationalité il va nous falloir
ouvrir les yeux des aveugles et dénoncer
les supercheries a déclaré monsieur
michel debré il ne peut y avoir ni
abandon ni transfert en marge de cette
actualité politique de rendez-vous cette
semaine mardi soir monsieur françois
mitterrand le premier secrétaire du
parti socialiste sera l'invité de notre
journal à 20 heures et puis le jeudi 22
jeudi prochain donc monsieur raymond
barre sera notre invité à 20h35 cette
fois pour cartes sur table une émission
qui aura lieu en direct à bayonne entre
le mardi et le jeudi
il ya le mercredi alors j'en profite
pour vous dire que mercredi prochain
notre magazine question de temps sera
consacré à l'espagne pour 337 milles
françaises et français jeunes les jours
les plus longs commence lors du bac a
sonné les philosophes des académies de
nantes et de rennes
nous commencerons à plancher dès demain
matin la majorité des candidats se
retrouveront toutefois les 27 et 28 juin
cette année ils sont donc 337 milles
soit à peu près 8 milles de plus que
l'an passé à aborder cette épreuve
fatidique pour les candidats bacheliers
la voie royale reste la série c qui
représente 19 6 % des candidats mais la
serre et la série -économie gagne peu à
peu du terrain il n'y avait que 15
lycéens sur cent l'an passé qu'il avait
choisi il y en a plus de 17 % cette
année présenté en 1809
il y avait 32 reçus au baccalauréat
cette année trois cent trente sept mille
candidats espèrent toucher obtenir le
premier grade universitaire alors
qu'avec le bac on a quand même des
possibilités
non elles sont pas du tout dans mon
canton et dans une section est sûr
qu'elles sont petites mais on a quand
même un choix surtout pas nous on est à
5 donc c'est des gens qu'on a choisi va
toujours des possibilités de s'orienter
vers le tourisme vert des choses comme
ça avant l'interprétariat mais il faut
quand même temps c'est une fois le bac 5
minimum de bagages c'est pour ça que je
pense à koné quoi c'est en fait ça
enfant il faut passer par la porte
baccalauréat mais pas n'importe comment
la réussite future dépend surtout de la
série de la mention de l'âge et du
milieu statistiquement un bachelier de
la série c'est à deux fois plus de
chances qu'un bachelier de la série des
de mener à bien des études scientifiques
par contre les amateurs de lettres seria
ont des débouchés de plus en plus
limitées et cette année ils ne
représentent que 26 % des inscrits
contre 47% en 68
une section débouchés très étroit où les
filles sont en majorité marché du
travail déjà qui est bien boucher va
être encore plus bouché pour nous en
plus de ça on a beaucoup moins de choix
au point de vue des universités de ce
qu'on voudrait faire énormément moins de
choix il ya toute une certaine mentalité
qui s'est développé autour des gens qui
sortent de a qui sont des gens moins bon
qui sont moins capables de raisonner qui
sont mois une certaine mentalité qui
s'est développé autour de ça qui est
absolument fausse parce qu'il ya
énormément de gens ici qui sont aura
parce qu'ils ont choisi d'être envahie
parce qu'ils aiment les langues parce
qu'ils aiment le français parce qu'ils
aiment la littérature là en permanence
le sentiment que finalement lancé demain
qu'en donne ne leur permettra pas
d'avoir un boulot une place dans cette
division du travail qui
leur apportera des satisfactions qui
leur permettra de se réaliser
de ces paniers
d'exister en tant 80 quoi qu'il en soit
trois innovations marque le bac 78 lors
à les supprimer pour ceux qui obtiennent
la moyenne de 10 le japonais a été
ajouté à la liste des langues vivantes
étrangères et après une interruption de
12 ans l'épreuve écrite
d'histoire-géographie rétabli ce qui
d'ailleurs suscitent une certaine
inquiétude tente auprès des professeurs
que des élèves c'était vraiment course
contre la montre être obligé de traiter
la résistance en un quart d'heure à la
fin de l'année par exemple ça me fait
mal au coeur
j'aimerais pouvoir leur en parler
davantage mais nous avons vraiment
vraiment été pris par le temps alors moi
je termine l'année
assez assez anxieuse finalement j'ai
essayé de faire le mieux possible la
plupart des collègues sont assez
angoissé malgré tous ces points de
détail 68% des candides en moyenne
réussi cet examen qui n'est pas toujours
considéré malgré les inconvénients du
bachotage et les hasards de la notation
comme un pilot fasse pas pile ou face à
ce que je pense quand même que si on a
été bons toute l'année il ya aucune
raison qu'on rate son bac mais
disons on peut paniquer on peut avoir un
moment de faiblesse des ça peut être ce
jour là c'est dommage à la veille du
baccalauréat je crois qu'on ne peut
donner que deux conseils le premier bien
sûr aux candidats soyez tout de même
confiante et le second aux parents
surtout rester calme
au terme de cinq ans d'autonomie le
gouvernement israélien acceptera de
réexaminer le statut de la judée et de
la samarie ainsi que le statut de la
bande de gaza voilà ce qu'a répondu
aujourd'hui officiellement le
gouvernement israélien aux questions que
lui posaient washington à propos de
l'avenir de la cisjordanie une réponse
il ne satisfera pas tout le monde et
notamment qui ne satisfera pas les pays
arabes
puisqu'israël pose en même temps un
préalable
l'autonomie administrative a décidé
jérusalem n'entrera en application qu
après l'établissement de la paix des
instructeurs chinois sont arrivés au
zaïre ils vont entraîner certains
éléments des forces armées zaïroises et
puis à propos du zaïre monsieur fidel
castro a répété ce week-end devant les
trois chaînes de télévision américaines
que son pays n'avait joué aucun rôle
dans l'invasion du shaba selon fidel
castro cuba n'a fourni ni armes ni
moyens de transport aux ex gendarme
katanga selon un journal britannique en
angola
l'angola qui est un pays voisin du zaïre
11 généraux soviétiques pas moins sont
arrivés il serait chargé de préparer le
lancement d'une vaste opération
militaire
d'ici la fin de l'année en namibie
toujours en afrique le train minéralier
qui circulent en mauritanie entre
nouadhibou et zohra a été attaquée
vendredi soir par une colonne du front
polisario se tâte
cette attaque a fait des victimes parmi
les scores de militaires mauritaniennes
les dégâts matériels seraient
relativement important l'avion
supersonique franco anglais concorde n'a
aucune chance de rester dans l'histoire
de l'aviation en tant que réussite
commerciale
le concorde pourtant poursuit son petit
bonhomme de chemin
amag de tout de même et il a transporté
depuis sa mise en service
cent mille passagers le 100.000ème est
arrivée à rio de janeiro cette semaine
alors nous avons voulu mieux le
connaître et martin ne large ouvert à
fait avec lui le voyage munich riom
j'offre par jour les munichois lève le
nez pour observer la fuite du temps qui
s'écoule boutade notre une chope de
bière et les notes de carillon de 9h 11h
17h de 9h à 17h on peut faire le tour de
la ville à pied mais aussi la quitter le
matin pour prendre l'après-midi à kayes
pyrénia à rillieux à condition bien sûr
de faire partie des privilégiés
choyé par leur société qui accepte de
payer le prix fort pour les protéger des
fatigues du voyage comme monsieur walter
landes le 100.000ème passagers à prendre
le concorde qui a taillé sur mesure pour
un supersonique hommes d'affaires
pressés succursale au brésil concorde
il a déjà pris 15 fois et ce n'est pas
terminé alors ce jour là il y avait une
petite fête en son honneur
petite fête qui ne masque pas tout à
fait les difficultés rencontrées par
concorde les incidents mécaniques dont
on a beaucoup parlé en huile moteur
surtout ne sont pas bien grave
plus préoccupant concorde coûte toujours
très cher et le seuil de rentabilité est
loin d'être atteint les appareils ne
vole pas à ces quatre heures chacun au
lieu de 7h30 les rumeurs d'arrêt
d'exploitation sont démenties par les
compagnies dont le supersonique portes
de couleur mais concorde pour sa survie
doit piquer du nez vers de nouvelles
escales nous n'avons pas besoin d'un
cinquième appareil je dirais même au
contraire que notre flotte actuelle de
quatre avions et plutôt insuffisamment
utilisées et que c'est ce qu'explique
que nous avons du mal à atteindre le bon
équilibre de rentabilité mais notre
problème est plutôt de développer notre
réseau je pense à des destinations comme
tokyo qui était inscrite dans la
prévision est que nous n'avons pas pu
encore réalisé je ne sais pas comment ni
quand nous pourrons les réaliser
difficile d'ailleurs pour un homme
d'affaires de résister à tout ordre
time is money bien sûr surtout pour les
américains la clientèle la plus
nombreuse avant les français 21%
ce jour là dans le concorde il y avait
bien un prince consort d'arabie saoudite
des femmes de footballeurs français
jackie kennedy avait failli le prendre
mais pour le reste les passagers
devaient ressembler à tous ceux des vols
concorde
beaucoup se connaissaient déjà cela
faisait très club d'habitués de haut vol
je n'ai aucun reproche à faire
évidemment c'est un peu moins
confortable qu'un 747 que ce qui compte
c'est la vitesse la rapidité
avec le 100.000ème passagers veuillez
donc à rio les femmes de l'équipe de
france de football
menu pour adoucir regret et blessures
elle descendait du concorde l'avion
commercial le plus rapide du monde
les il a bien du mal lui aussi a gagné
sa finale contre les équipes américaines
ou japonaises une commercialisation
rapide l'explosion d'hier à la courneuve
a finalement causé la mort de quatre
personnes le jeune garçon de 13 ans qui
avait disparu était mort enseveli sous
les décombres son corps a été découvert
en fin d'après-midi par les sapeurs
pompiers
curieuse affaire à evian les bains à
evian les bains le commissariat de cette
ville a été attaquée cette nuit quatre
hommes s'en sont pris aux trois gardiens
de la paix qui était de service quatre
hommes qui étaient armés de pistolets
mitrailleurs et de revolver de des
gardiens ont été rapidement neutralisée
mais le troisième a réussi à ouvrir le
feu l'un des gangsters devait être alors
drillet venant blessés et les quatre
hommes se sont enfuis avant de parler du
sport du sport de compétition je vous
propose de revenir sur ce congrès
mondial de la médecine qui s'est tenu à
cannes cette semaine mille médecins
s'intéressant touche au sport se sont
réunis ils ont parlé de la compétition
ils ont même qu'on peut être ils ont
même été compétiteurs entre eux mais ils
ont aussi évoqué tous les problèmes que
nous pouvons connaître à 30 40 50 ou 60
ans lorsque nous pratiquons une activité
sportive le tennis la natation bien levé
leurs conclusions
elles sont assez simples pour être en
forme surtout après 40 ans il n'est pas
nécessaire de vouloir battre des records
en revanche et jusqu'à 75 ans - il
paraît indispensable de prendre de
l'exercice c'est d'ailleurs ce qu'a
expliqué à martin à la réunion un
spécialiste scandinave de la condition
physique
si vous regardez mon passeport
j'ai 56 ans
mais si vous vous intéressez à mon âge
physiologie celui de mon coeur de mes
artères ou de mes muscles
j'ai 35 ans et je suis dans la force de
l'âge l'homme qui se vante ainsi et
l'expert mondial de la condition
physique
chaque matin à stockholm il fait comme
ici pour nous à cannes 6 km de footing
ou de bicyclette il s'est forgé un coeur
pour la vie depuis l'âge de pierre dit
il slam est conçu pour un travail
physique intense et non pour leur peau
il n'est jamais trop tard pour en
prendre conscience
l'homme est aussi très paresseux
s'adapte très vite à l'inactivité est ce
que les machines et phase de travail à
ça il faut donc lui réapprendre à
l'activité
et cela est possible jusqu'à 75 ans au
moins mais passée la jeunesse
l'important ce n'est plus de faire un
exploit de vouloir gagner à tout prix
une autre compétition c'est de rester en
forme et d'admettre de se dépenser
seulement avec des personnes de son âge
et de son niveau avec toujours un avis
médical passé 40 ans ajoute les médecins
français qui redoute plus que les
scandinaves
l'excès de zèle des sportifs sur le tard
il est obligatoire de pratiquer une
spécialité sur plusieurs petits efforts
par ci par là elle mieux qu'un gros
effort une fois par les spécialistes de
la médecine sportive croit en effet plus
à long terme au cyclotourisme et aux
randonnées qu'à l'épreuve
contre-la-montre à part les fanatiques
du sport la plupart d'entre nous n'avons
pas le courage de nous astreindre toute
l'année un entraînement intensif
il ya d'autres moyens d'améliorer d'au
moins 20% notre oxygénation et notre
volume cardiaques et de rajeunir notre
coeur de 10 ans par exemple dans la vie
courante choisir l'escalier ordinaires
plutôt que le mécanique ou l'ascenseur
pour une ménagère penser à porter à bout
de bras ces provisions au lieu de les
mettre sur un chariot
et puis on peut aussi décidé de
descendre de l'autobus ou du métro une
deux stations plus tôt et penser tout au
long de la journée à se dépenser
mais ne volera nommé théorie nouveau
revers ces pratiques mais assez de
conseils assez épuré
passons aux actes
manger de tout ce qu'on veut tant qu'on
vous voulez avoir qu'il faisait beau
quand même en sport je ne reviendrai pas
sur le football sinon pour vous rappeler
que vous avez une nouvelle fois rendez
vous avec nos envoyés spéciaux en
argentine quelques minutes après minuit
ce soir nous retransmettrons en effet le
grand choc de cette journée
brésil argentine en espagne c'est
l'américain kenny roberts qui a remporté
le deuxième grand prix d'espagne
motocycliste dans la catégorie des 750
cm cube le vénézuélien johnny cecotto
termine 2e et le français christian
sarron troisième le midi libre s'est
terminée aujourd'hui à espalion c'est le
belge de munich qui a remporté l'étape
et c'est l'italien bortolotto qui
triomphe finalement au classement
général de ce midi libre et puis il y
avait un tiers c'est aujourd'hui à
auteuil
car c'est qui ce cours est dans la 4e
tour s'il s'agissait du grand steeple
chase de paris une course de 6500 mètres
réservée aux chevaux de 5 ans et plus
les parieurs avaient le choix entre 18
chevaux au départ au bout de six mille
mètres ils n'étaient plus que 16 en
course finalement le grandissime favori
dont et lyon a déçu il ne termine que
quatrième et à l'arrivée c'est mon
filleul suivi de piau mares et de shinko
qui constitue la combinaison gagnante
la combinaison donc 17 10 et passent
plus